foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
these rings
signify that
I'm sorry
that was on silent
um
these rings
Thomas
[Music]
okay sorry sorry excuse me this is an
emergency
what it's better to be important I just
are you skiing snowboarding actually but
I need your help now life or death
situation this very second I need you to
use the ring I gave you to save me like
right now okay slow down slow down I
don't even know where you are you just
got a picture where you want the ring to
go so picture this
okay okay
hang on
[Music]
did you throw it
I think I mixed up the Rings when I was
teasing JoJo what where is it then where
is it
[Music]
you don't want to know oh
dude Tom I very much want to know before
I become a hedgehog flavored snow cone
hang tight buddy I got this with this
ring
hey hi
uh everything okay bud not really what
are you doing this is gonna sound really
crazy but I'm gonna need to see that
ring for just one second one second have
you lost your mind I'm gonna give it
right back I promise please Randall it's
really important can I no bro go sit
down Randall give me the ring please
just okay Randall don't look at him look
at me put the ring on my finger you're
gonna rain and listen to me Randall look
at me ring on my finger give me the ring
give me just one second put a ring on it
please love okay with this ring yes man
I'm so sorry about that
foreign
[Music]